[Music]
yeah I understand mr. white I get no
miss right I get yes yes mr. white yes I
will I will have my article on your desk
lickety-split
yes sir I know that no one says
lickety-split anymore um but although
although you you do still say great
Caesar's ghost which is a bit of a
throwback No yes sir I'm very aware that
we are not talking about you right yes
sir
yes I will have that to you look hello
hang on we're hearing on the possible
explosion aboard the venture here's all
we know at this time there are over 200
people aboard the craft there are no
further details but keep it right here
and we'll continue to bring you the very
latest we can only hope wherever he is
he's seeing this
you
I pray she's watching this she is
[Music]
Mayday Mayday we have experienced a hull
breach and catastrophic engine failure
Supergirl
and hey cuz it's good to see you this
looks like a job for the both of us
absolutely
I mean it was terrible it was awesome
I dreamt of this moment both of us - you
know you didn't tell me that you know
Clark Kent I'm with her I have anything
in my teeth yeah your cousin smells
terrific enough
this is my cousin sue permit questions
how do you shave
in order to live we must keep staring
we're moving back to Gotham
that I got top credit on this one does
it not even a little bit
hey youtubers is Charlie so a whole
bunch of new Supergirl season two
Superman footage let's break it down
a lot of good stuff in this but if you
didn't catch it they named Rob Gotham at
like the very end of this we're moving
back to Gotham so we know Batman is in
here somewhere and this is supergirls
earth she's still on a different earth
from Barry and Oliver so both of those
shows have mentioned Batman related
things so Batman is in here somewhere
Batman is in the multiverse of course he
exists but the way they're presenting
this version of Superman seems like he
hasn't been Superman for more than like
five or six years not that long in the
grand scheme of things usually like if
you read him in the comics now he's been
Superman for a long time the earth has
been through numerous catastrophe that
he's saved it from so everybody's like
oh yeah it's Superman like it's no big
deal that you run into him on the street
but the way everybody reacts to him is
just hilarious this is his first time on
TV in a long time so naturally you have
to have a moment like this where you
introduce him is a god among men so
they'll have like the really fun moment
then they'll have the conflict of the
episode the initial conflict obviously
that brings them together is this Space
Shuttle crash that they both see from
their cities Clark and metropolis
talking to Perry White
nobody talks like that anymore well that
is a deep cut you can definitely see a
lot of the Richard Donner Christopher
Reeve Superman in this so I think it'll
be much closer to the tone of that then
it'll be to the tone of the modern DC
movies so if you have friends that
aren't really sure what's going on with
this version of Superman make sure you
explain to them that this is Richard
Donner Christopher Reeve type Superman
we're not talking about Schneider verse
Superman this Superman actually has some
personality in him not to say that I
don't like Henry cavils version of
Superman I just feel like they're
working towards a Superman that has a
personality they just haven't got there
yet like the way they talked about the
changes they've made to the Justice
League movie like they were always going
to get to that optimistic hopeful
version of Superman but now they're
getting there that much faster because
of the response to the DC movie so far
we get a little tease for Lena Luthor
Luthor Corp she's going to be a really
important figure in season 2 but not
necessarily the main antagonist as I
think it's a bit of a misdirect you
would naturally
expect someone from LuthorCorp to be the
main villain of any Supergirl Superman's
story but that's Cadmus labs metallo is
going to be like the big bad of this
first opener with Superman he's not
anywhere in here but really this is just
meant to set up the team up like this is
what happens to bring them together this
is what the tone is going to feel like
but metallo shows up [ __ ] gets real they
throw down big time so they've already
talked a lot more about what's going on
with Superman this season about how he
and Supergirl were gonna butt heads a
little bit because he has his own idea
about how justice should be served she
has her own idea - it's kind of the same
thing with the flash season 3 you have
the Wally West flash now you have Barry
calling him kid flash even iris West in
that flash trailers like listen to Barry
Wally he's the flash as if Wally is like
the junior version of the flash so he's
going to be kind of resentful that Cara
might feel a little resentful for
Superman because the world does hold him
up as this God and she's only just been
on the scene so she hasn't really had
the big victories that Superman has but
other big things that we see in this we
get a little tease for Miss Martian here
with the Martian Manhunter scene Miss
Martian is going to be an older
character so she's not going to be like
young justice age Miss Martian she'll
have more parody with adult Martian
Manhunter
then there's ma Nell who they've also
teased is going to be something of an
antagonist with Cara he comes from Dax
um and has a bit more of a Kryptonian
Sensibility I think just the way they've
teased him so Cara and Clark have both
kind of been Americanized like they've
been living on the earth for so long
that they just assimilated the culture
that is not the case with Ma Nell so
he's going to be somewhere between say
like Zod's followers like imagine how
hardcore they are like they want to
subjugate the earth in Korra in Clarke
so they're doing way more comic-book
stuff and I think they're holding back
less I think the tendency in season 1
was the kind of water down a lot of the
genres stuff make it really easy to
follow for people that had absolutely no
idea what's going on with the characters
now I don't think that's as big a
concern because who does not understand
who's Superman and Supergirl are even if
you haven't read comics you still kind
of get the character so just expect them
to do less hand-holding which is kind of
frustrating because it's like okay let's
get to the good stuff tell me how crazy
you can get
in speaking of crazy I'll do a separate
video for this because there's new arrow
footage for arrow season 5 but they've
been teasing the hundredth episode with
a bunch of different pictures Stephen
Amell of amongst the pictures that he's
been posting posted this him just
casually sitting on this park bench next
to Deathstroke in full armor in the
funny thing about it is it just like a
really sunny day everything looks really
nice so you're like what are they having
like a picnic together what's going on I
have absolutely no idea so whatever is
happening in the hundredth episode
Deathstroke is going to be a part of it
so hell yeah but I'll talk more about
that when I do my arrow video tomorrow
so what's going to happen is is there is
a new Gotham episode tonight they're
debuting the new poison ivy so that
video post in the morning then I'll do
that arrow trailer video they'll
probably be some new flash footage
there'll be a lot of new trailers this
week just because everything is coming
back next week but the only exceptions
to that are Supergirl and legends of
tomorrow they are in two weeks so I'll
just remind people as I post DC videos
so let me know in the comments though
what are you most excited about for
Supergirl season 2 I feel like it's
going to be so much more fun for
comic-book people this year is gonna be
some super deep cuts so it'll be fun to
do Easter Egg videos but if you guys
didn't know the flash season 2 giveaway
still going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's just a gift
certificate for the value of the season
to blu-ray so just a quick heads-up if
you guys have been having trouble with
the end cards that I've been using
lately like the new end cards these are
what YouTube says the requirements are
there probably slowly rolling it out to
every other platform so like if you have
a Windows Phone or if you're in a
browser that they don't support they'll
probably get there eventually
but if you are having problems just
switch to one of these browsers if
you're on desktop or you can always
check the description for the links that
I talked about so when like when I'm
pointing the cards at the end of videos
those links are down below in the
description while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for the last
big flash season 3 trailer I posted you
can click here for the big Luke Cage
trailer I posted this morning thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight